- They're too long, they like 6'8.
How am I supposed to catch-?
- Listen, you're playing
with the big boys now.
If you want your Madden rating to go up,
it doesn't matter how tall they are.
- You right. You right.
I need Tom Brady out
here, though.
- Oh, hello, and welcome to "Underrated,"
presented by State Farm.
Not sure if you know,
but State Farm is known for two things.
No. 1, not being an actual farm.
No. 2, their surprisingly great rates.
You know who else is gonna surprise people
with their greatness this season?
Rookie wide receiver Jerry Jeudy.
I picked him cuz I saw him in Alabama,
and his ratings are not high enough.
There's only one thing we need to do.
Let's call Madden.
All right, Jake, let's
get Jeudy's rating up.
Call my Madden ratings adjuster.
- [Jake:] Calling Madden rate adjuster.
- Clint, ol' buddy,
ol' pal, how you doin'?
You ever hear of Jerry Jeudy?
- Oh, yeah, I've heard of Jerry Jeudy.
Very polished coming out of college.
- All right, it's time.
Jake, call Jerry Jeudy, aka. Double J.
Get him on the phone.
- [Jake:] Calling Double J.
- There he is, Jerry Jeudy.
A man of speed, a man of aggression,
just look at him.
Jerry, this is Clint.
He's a Madden ratings adjuster.
Clint, this is the legendary Jerry Jeudy.
All right, man.
So I talked to Clint over at Madden,
and I asked them to do something
that they have never done before.
They're gonna give you the opportunity
to possibly raise your
initial rookie ratings.
Do you like your ratings?
- A 74?
That's a C.
- All right, so there were two categories
I think you were actually very good at
where I think Madden is sleeping on you.
Catch in traffic and medium route running.
But I want to start with catch in traffic first,
and Clint, you're the guy to talk to.
How do I improve these two?
- Hmm, all right, so catch in traffic,
what we use that rating for is
determining the catch chance.
So, if you could come up with some drills
to test his concentration
around distractions
while he's catching some difficult passes,
that'd be a great place to start.
- Yeah, I'm ready to improve that.
- OK, Clint,
medium route running.
What kind of routes am I
looking for to test this?
- Oh, you're looking at about
the 20- to 40-yard range.
Intermediate type routes,
deep ins, deep outs.
We're gonna be looking at
his foot work efficiency
at the cut, explosion.
- [Jerry:] This what I like to
do right here, route running.
This is me.
- I mean, Jerry, I gotta
imagine never in your life
has anyone said you're a
74 in football at any time?
- Nah, nah.
But, hey, like I said,
I just gotta show 'em.
- Clint, are you gonna
take this serious, though?
I don't want him to do all these routes
and then you guys don't bump him up.
- So, we're the Madden ratings adjusters.
We always take this seriously.
- Thanks, Clint. I'll talk to you soon.
- All right. Take care.
- [Adam:] All right, bud.
Since we couldn't put any
defenders out there to cover you,
we got a little creative, Jerry.
I call it the Car Dealership Surprise.
Now, Jerry, the NFL is different than college.
When you cross the middle,
there's gonna be some
amazing defensive backs
with long wingspans.
So we've set up six sky dancers,
and at the top of your route,
they'll be fluttering in your face.
So you gotta concentrate
and catch the ball.
- I feel confident, though.
I've been doing this my whole life.
Oh.
Oh!
That was one right there.
- [Adam:] Defense. That's
good defense right there.
- This some good work.
- [Adam:] Coming across the middle.
Ah!
Jeudy!
Dance on 'em!
- Oh.
Oh!
- Like it or not, ladies and gentlemen,
that's all we're gonna be seeing in Denver
for years to come.
- That was good right there.
- I thought that early on
you were having some
trouble seeing them all.
- No, no, no.
- But I feel like
after a while, you got the hang of it.
- No, that's not what
it was. You're wrong.
Bad throws.
Where he at, where he?
He running. Look. He running.
You see.
But it's all good, though.
You know, receivers gotta make
the quarterback look good.
- So unfortunately,
that's gonna hurt your
teammate rating, though.
I'm only kidding.
But you did kinda throw him under the bus.
All right, so Jerry,
we're gonna have you run a few medium-range routes.
First, I gotta show you a little something.
Here is your new Madden
character doing these routes.
And I want you to pay special
attention to how he moves,
because I think we can
convince the adjuster
that you are way better than this.
- Uh.
I ain't a little bit too bad now.
I ain't gonna lie. That's not too bad.
But I could do better.
- You're loving this right now.
Look at your face though.
You are loving this.
- Yeah, it look smooth, though.
It looks smooth.
But I'mma show you smoother.
- [Adam:] Tear up the earth, Jerry Jeudy.
- Oh!
- [Adam:] That was a dime right there.
- That was a good throw.
Bend down with me. Bend down with me.
- All right, talk to me, man.
- It's different running routes on air
and running routes against a defender.
Against a defender, you doing more moves,
hesitating.
Then, oh, then stop like that,
so it kind of different.
- Are you tired right now?
- Yeah.
[Inhaling and exhaling]
I'm back.
So, what we run, a corner post?
- Yeah, I wanna see the man in action.
I wanna see the release.
- You gotta see the footwork, though.
You gotta back up so you see the footwork.
The footwork was get 'em.
- That's what I wanna see.
- Oh!
- What happened, Jerry?
Wind got ahold of it?
- That was a bad one.
Hair got in my face a little bit.
It touched my hand, though. No excuses.
- You know what?
We're gonna learn from this.
We're gonna get right back at it.
- Yes, sir.
Let's get back to it.
Oh!
Came out the hat.
- I'll say this, man.
If you can fake the hat off your head,
you're gonna fake defenders
out of their shoes.
That was perfect.
- Appreciate it.
- Now, I'm gonna take all this.
I'm gonna send it to my homie at Madden.
Do you think that we put
good film on tape today?
- I think so.
I think I ran some good routes.
I think we did pretty good today.
- You got any choice words
you'd like for me to include
with your submission tape?
- I better be an 80 by the end of the day.
- Well, hold on to that,
cuz when I call you next time,
I'm gonna have the adjuster on the line
and you can tell him right to his face.
- Hey, Adam, man,
I'm looking forward to,
for you letting him know what I did today
and to see if they
could improve my rating.
- I got you, man. We're gonna talk soon.
Clint, I'm telling you the kid is young,
but he is going to be a stud.
The video showed it.
What were your reactions?
Let me know the truth.
- We saw some really good things.
We saw some things that
could use some improvement.
You know, good video, good research.
- Let's get Jerry Jeudy on the call.
Jerry Jeudy in the car.
- Hey, Jerry.
- What's up, man?
- Clint, you said there's
adjustments.
Let me hear what these
adjustments are.
- So we are gonna actually
bump him up one point
in medium route running.
He is the No. 1-rated rookie in medium route running.
- I did all that, we're
just getting 1 percent?
- Yeah, it's tough, man.
For a rookie, we gotta
leave some room to grow
for you young kids.
For consolation,
I can tell you that based
on some of the athleticism
you showed running through
those flying, waving banners,
you are going to go up one point
in short route running as well.
- Hey!
OK, so we went up a point in medium
and a point in short?
- Could be a little bit better,
but we're making progress. It's all good.
- Clint, I'm putting
it all on you.
Let's get down to it.
Is Jerry Jeudy
underrated?
- I'm gonna say in this case, no,
even though there is
going to be an adjustment.
No, we have Jerry rated
pretty close to accurate.
- Hmm.
- Well, yeah, I agree.
Double the "Hmm."
- It was a little bit because
the quarterback wasn't great.
- I blame the quarterback on that one.
- Jerry, you're the man.
Clint, I appreciate it.
I love both of you.
And Jerry is gonna be
a 99 by next season.
I can feel it.
Deal with it.
This has been "Underrated."
I am Adam Lefkoe.
And, as always, we are sponsored by
the surprisingly great
rates of State Farm.
Check 'em out.